-Our next guest is an
award-winning writer whose wor
you know from
"Saturday Night Live,"
the TBS series "Miracle
Workers," "An American Pickle.
His latest book, "New Teeth,
is available on July 27th.
Please welcome back to the sho
our very good friend Simon Rich.
Hello, Simon.
It's so good to see you.
-Great to see you.
Thanks for having me.
-I'm thrilled to have you.
I'm wondering how, as a writer
you managed during the pandemic.
I've always known you to b
an incredibly prolific --
like, somebody who works
very hard at their craft.
I'm guessing -- and I hope thi
doesn't come off wrong --
that you might have thrived.
-Yeah. I tried to be as
productive as possible
and putting as many hours
as ever, if not more,
but seeing you hold up the book,
I now am a little self-conscious
'cause I feel like the boo
should be longer,
given the severity and lengt
of the global pandemic.
Like, if I can't crack 300 pages
in 2020,
then, you know, it's never
going to happen, probably.
-Yeah, I'm looking now.
Acknowledgements is starting
at like 225.
So that's pretty weak.
-Exactly.
-You have two daughters.
What are they,
four and not even a year?
-Yeah, four and six months
Yeah, it's pretty amazing.
It's very difficult,
as you know, but the thing
that's great about kids is
it takes them a pretty long time
to be able to form memories.
So, as a parent, like, the first
four years of parenting,
it's basically
like exhibition baseball.
[ Laughter ]
It doesn't really count.
There's no true record of it
It's still low stakes.
Like Tim Tebow is still ou
there taking a pass.
[ Laughter ]
-It must be, you know,
nice to have, like,
a life-changing experience
like children, when you ar
someone who's looking for
new things to write about.
Obviously, it's a wealth
of subject matter.
-Yeah. I mean, material
isn't like the sole reason
why I had kids, but it's,
like, I would say,
probably somewhere
in the top 10.
-You've had a lot of
stories published
over the years
in "The New Yorker."
One of the stories is in
this collection, "The Big Nap.
It must still be nice to b
published in "The New Yorker."
And I'm wondering,
over the years,
have you ever gotten a sense
you ever been on a subway
or anything and realized
people are reading
either a story of yours
or one of your books?
-Yes. It's happened probably
like, you know,
three or four times in my life
Always on the subway
in New York City.
And it's just
absolutely terrifying.
And I just lock eyes with them
creepily from across the train
And I'm just, like, so anxious
about whether or not
they're going to smirk,
which is really the best
you could ever hope for
from a piece of written comedy
And there is nothing more
horrible than them reading
the first paragraph and then
just turning the page.
But I guess if you're like
an actor or a stand-up,
that's your day-to-day
existence.
And I've always been so shocke
at the bravery of somebody
who can kind of live in that
terror for an hour at a time
'Cause I can barely handle i
for a few fleeting seconds
-We worked together at "SNL.
It was a time I look back on
fondly, to the point that
I probably overlook exactl
how much stress and anxiet
filled those years.
You've done a lot since you've
left "SNL," created two shows,
wrote for "The Simpsons,"
multiple books, films.
Is it true that that's still
where all your stress dreams
come from?
-Yes. I have exclusively
"SNL" nightmares.
I have only had
"Saturday Night Live" nightmares
since leaving the show.
It's always pretty much
the same.
Lorne's on a horse.
-Uh-huh.
[ Laughter ]
-He's looking down at me
from a very great height.
And there's always been
some kind of paperwork snafu
and as a result, I have to g
on camera and perform,
which is not my job as a writer.
But he's always saying, "You
have to go out there right now."
Then he speeds off on his horse.
And I'll say in these dreams
you are in all of them.
-Okay.
-And you were my --
you were my head writer
when I worked for that show.
And you were also
a real mentor figure.
And you were really nice to me
during that time in my life.
But in these dreams,
you do not help me.
[ Laughter ]
You are not openly antagonistic,
but you never try --
you never listen to reason
You're always like,
"Lorne's already galloped
to the control room."
-[ Laughs ]
-"And I hope you know the lyrics
to 'Poker Face,'
'cause Lady Gaga's contrac
didn't go through,
and you have to do it
right now."
You're never pitching like
"Oh, I could ask Maya Rudolph.
She's a great singer, and she'
already in the building."
You're just like,
"It has to be you."
-Once the horse leaves,
that's it.
We got to go.
-I don't know why it's a horse
I think it's a Canadian thing.
-[ Laughs ]
-But have you ever had
that same dream?
Because, if so, you know -
-All my dreams are entirely --
My "SNL" dreams are always tha
Wally is nowhere to be seen.
And that the cue cards
are nowhere there.
And it's always someone saying
like, "But you know it, right?
I mean like, "Oy, oy, oy.
I do not."
You also went from "SNL"
to Pixar, which,
when you think about,
like, the writing process
is the most jarring transition
you can imagine.
-Yeah. It was like weeks later
And it was completely strange,
because at "SNL,"
you have six days to creat
90 minutes of entertainment.
And then, at Pixar it's like
you have six years
to create 90 minutes.
And so, leaving an environment
where literally Friday night
it's like, "Well, we have
no cold open or monologue.
Like, we need to --"
And people are in tears,
racing around, frantic.
And then, like, three week
later I'm at Pixar,
and it's like --
the meetings are like,
"Alright, we've been at this
three years, we really need to
like, pick a lane in terms o
this character's eyebrows now.
I think we need to --
we don't need to crack it today,
but let's start to dial in
these eyebrows."
And people are just in the poo
and lazing about in hammocks
-I guess I didn't know
you were actual classmates
But you went to Harvard,
and you were classmates with
Mark Zuckerberg.
Did you ever cross paths wit
him then?
-Yes. So, I never met him
at Harvard.
We were in the same class,
but I never met him.
I think it's 'cause we hung ou
with different crowds.
I was more in
the writing comedy crowd,
and he was more focused on
developing a vise-like gri
on democracy
and dominating the world.
So I think he hung out wit
different folks.
But I do remember
when Facebook started.
I remember that week and -
or The Facebook
as it was known then.
And I learned about it
from what everybody considered
to be the creepiest guy
at Harvard,
which is really -- that's --
"creepiest guy at Harvard" i
like saying like fastest skate
in the NHL.
It's like a big -- you know,
it's a big deal, and he --
-A lot of competition.
-A lot of competition for that
yeah, for that spot.
And he called everybody over
and he was like,
"Hey, everybody, check out
this new website
that lets you stalk girls.
And he showed us The Facebook.
And it was like, "You just typ
in the girl's name,
there's their face, there'
the list of books she likes,
so you can pretend
that you like them too."
And then, back then, durin
the early days of Facebook
it would often list
their class schedule.
So you could physically trac
somebody in real time.
And I remember this guy
literally,
he was like, "Science Center B."
And he shut his computer,
and he grabbed whatever
Dave Eggers novel
she had said she liked
and just ran out of the room
And I looked at everybody
and I said,
"Okay, I am making a predictio
right now.
This Mark kid, he is going t
get in a lot of trouble."
[ Laughter ]
"He's going to get a dean'
warning at least."
And everybody kind of nodded
solemnly.
But I was wrong.
[ Laughter ]
He became very, very successful.
But that's why
I've never been on Facebook,
because I associate it with,
like, truly this, like,
creepy, evil dude,
and I just think Facebook
is really awful,
but I do invest.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, I mean, you have to
-Yeah.
'Cause Zuckerberg isn't the only
Jew from the class of '06.
I have two bat mitzvahs
to pay for, so you know.
-Sure. Nobody would judge yo
for that, Simon.
-Yeah, exactly.
-Buddy, it is so good
to see you, as always.
Congratulations on the book.
"New Teeth" is available
everywhere July 27th.
Please remember to support
your local and independent
book stores.